the GSB Research Fellows program is a
two-year pre doctoral program that
allows students between their
undergraduate and their PhD to obtain
in-depth research experience and form
close mentoring relationships with
faculty the research fellows program I
think is fantastic in that regard
that you can over a two-year period of
time really get to know if a PhD is
right for you you get to work with
faculty on a day to day basis doing
research in a way that you can't in the
other way delving into this completely
unknown area of research and trying to
navigate with them that has been really
eye-opening and really exciting not to
mention a big challenge but that
challenge has been a lot of fun to be
able to overcome when you see the
process that the faculty go through to
get to that end goal seeing the mistakes
seeing the ideas that don't pan out
seeing the things that people try you
realize that it's not so inaccessible
but it does take a lot of art and
practice and craft I think about
research when I am a senior podcast or
when I'm reading a book and I have all
these questions and this program gives
me a framework and an environment to
know how to answer those questions in a
rigorous and meaningful way well in the
process I think people will discover
that there are some holes in their own
background potentially so we encourage
our fellows to take classes here at
Stanford Eider classes offer that to GSB
or and the broader Stanford community if
you're a research fellow you get to take
classes in any department at Stanford
including economics political science
math and statistics so it really allows
you to fill in any gaps that you may
have in your transcript one thing that's
really special about the GSB here at
Stanford is that it's really built over
the past few decades a tradition of
research excellence
I think fellows get to be immersed in
that culture and that's tremendously
valuable they'll be encouraged to voice
their opinions to think critically and
to be active participants really in the
research process and you're also sort of
co-located with the GSB ph.d program
which means that you can have peer
relationships and social relationships
with PhD students who are just a little
bit further along the career that the
students are embarking upon what strikes
me the most about the research
environment here at Stanford is how
collaborative it is the research fellows
sit alongside of the PhD students and we
see how they on a daily basis are
working with one another to answer
questions similarly with faculty we see
them working together on different
projects men really creates an
environment where we want to work
together in order to answer our own
research questions
another unique part of our program is
that we emphasize the mentorship these
are really impactful relationships and I
think by making that integral part of
the organization of the program and the
purpose of the program we really
prioritize the students more than most
programs that I've seen I was talking
with my faculty members
and she said I'm very invested in your
success I've been a lot to me that she
would you know be so invested each
quarter the faculty gather to discuss
the fellows progress we talk about the
fellow skill development how they are
acquiring the tools that they need to
progress in a ph.d program and we also
discuss their life's ambitions and goals
one of the most valuable things about
this program is you get to work with
such a wide variety of professors in
different fields on different projects
and I think what an amazing community
this program has to offer you what
amazing tools it's going to teach you
and the opportunity to work with people
that you would otherwise never be able
to work with and so if research is what
you're interested in if research is what
you like to do this program is
definitely something you should consider